Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier -
and welcome to the Try Not to Smile Challenge.
Now, I know some of you have probably seen these videos before, but
There is a subreddit called r/MadeMeSmile
That does nothing but compile these videos,
That are only there to warm the dark, cold, stone hearts
That we all have in our chests.
And hopefully, when I'm watching these videos,
I'll just remember all of the deathly, sour memories,
And like, horrible voices inside my head;
And will NOT be happy or smile at any of these videos that we're about to see.
Now, that's the challenge - I don't think I'm gonna win it because
I'm a-I'm a joyous baby at heart.
Inside my body, is a baby?
No, I'm not pregnant
That's not right.
Inside-insi- inside somewhere in me,
There's a smiling baby - that's just so giggly
It's just a giggly little shit.
Inside of me, and - alright this is getting weird- this analogy is weird.
I'm a giggly bitch. And that includes seeing things
Like these videos that you're about to see
That are happy and fun and free and are gonna be great so-
We're gonna get to that right now - you ready?
I'm ready.  I'm not ready.
This one's called "Dog tries to stop stream of water"
DON'T smile. If you smile I will come over to your house, and beat the shit outta you.
and then hug you.
Because, you're obviously trying to be happy so I should probably not... beat... you up *deep insecure breath*
Anyway, whatever.
[Splashing noises and happy music]
mmmmmMMMMMMMMM-- *dying on the inside*
THAT'S NOT CUTE
[Splashing]
MMMMMMMMMM
THAT'S NOT CUTE - THAT IS NOT CUTE
THAT'S NOT A CUTE A PUPPO!
Okay, alright - alright the charm has worn off.
Obviously that doggo can't stop that whole river...
OHH BUT GODDAMN IT HE'S GONNA TRY- OOOOHH GODDD
This is the most impossible challenge I've ever had in my life.
Oh it's soooo cuuute! - WHATISTHAT?!
What is THAAT? MMMMM
MMM MMMM
That's the thi- that's the same thing Maggie does! When she nee-doesn't wanna take a bath!
*little breath* Mmmmm this is gonna be nothing but animals being cute and adorable!
Ooooh such a PUPPO!! That was such a good puppo!!!!
[Muttering] What's this one?
God damn it- it's another dog! Awww!
[Audible intake of breath]
I'm gonna cry! Ohhhh I'm gonna cry!
Awhhhhh
Mark: I'm gonna cry! [Muffled noise in background]
Oh save that puppo!!!
Mmmmmm-!
[Mark makes a small sobbing noise]
Ohhhhhh noooooooo. I didn't think this would be the try not to cry challenge! Oohhhhh help!!!
(Mark makes sobbing/laughing noises)
Ohohohoh noooooo-
Oh noooo!
Is such a good puppo! She looks like Chica sooo much!
Oh God where's Chica?
I need to hug Chica!
I gotta- I gotta hug Chica like right now!
Please Chica I need you to help me finish this video!
Oh-
Oh no!
Ohh noo! Chica!
(Gives Chica an audible lil smooch)
Awh puppo, ohh puppo! Oh puppo! Awww-*dying noises*
OOOHHHH....
Oohh-
AAAAAAH HELL YEAH I'LL DONATE! Oh my god...
Awh, frick-a-dick...
Ohohoh oohhhhhh- Awh fuck this challenge!
[Happy music starts playing]
Okay- I just donated 1,000 dollars to Hope for Paws because MY GOD
That video was amazing, and just oh my god Chica...
Oh you're such a sweetheart!
Chica! I love you!
We're only like, what is this, like, 3 videos in, and MY GOD, I've already destroyed the challenge!
[Calm dog barking]
Nah, that's not cute- God damn it it's just nothing but dogs!
[Tango music starts playing]
I am a heartless bastard. I will not smile at this adorableness!
In fact, it's not adorable at all!!
It's not cute- not in any way! Oh look at those little stump arms though! Oh the emus!
[Soft giggling]
[Louder giggling] Ah, nope-nah-nah can- oh!
[Very quiet giggle]
Mmm mMMMm.. nope, not cute. Not cute, not cute at all. Not adorable!
Awh, they broke it.
How could they break it?! Mahm, mahm, mahm, mahm!
Ooh hey,  how-how's it goin there? Hey. Oh Jeez!
MUUUUUH. Aww, what's that?! Ahh what is that?
WhAT iS ThAT?!!
It's a BABY OSTRICH!
NOOOooooOOoOOOOO.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ONE BEFORE!
NOOOOOOOOOOO! [Shrieking] NOOOOOOOOO!
Ohhhh, nooo! They're SO CUTE! Oh my god they're so tiny! They'll grow up to be so monstrous!
Is that a baby emu?
I DON'T WANNA SUBSCRIBE TO WATCH THEM GROW!!!
AAAHH. I want them to stay that forever! Ahhh stay- whoa nooo!
This is the greatest sub-reddit that anyone has ever... ever... done.
Noooo.... Noo, that was cuute! It's two grown men being cute and adorable! [laughing] nooooo!
Jesus, alright, so, this didn't go well. I, uh, that-di-I-di- I failed, I failed bad, I failed hard, and, uh...
Yeah, I have no remorse for it! That was frickin adorable, that sub-reddit is soo cool, I'll try to link every video that I-that I saw here in the description
and-and also I'll link to the sub-reddit,
It's just chock-full of THAT stuff.
So if you need a smile today, if you need to be a little happy, Go to that sub-red and plow through all the videos there. They're all amazing.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching, lemme know what you thought of this one, i-I think it's a nice change from the-
the horrible videos that I have to pour through just to get to the funny ones, you know what I mean?!
But, either way, it's pretty cool, and I like it a lot, uh, god... Touches my heart.
[Quiet sniffle]
Anyway, so thank you again everybody for watching,  and as always, I will see you, in the next video. Buh-bye!!!